Hi, I'm Markus Philips.
I'm the Dean and Co-Founder of Hack Reactor an immersion school for
software engineering in San Francisco.
We developed an outcome driven and
data driven approach to education called Rapid Iteration Teaching.
I like to think of myself as the educational equivalent of Brad Pitt in
Money Ball, but it may be more accurate to compare me to Joanna Hill.
Before founding Hack Reactor, I led technical training initiatives at Twitter,
worked on their back-end anti-spam systems and led the front-end framework team.
I left Twitter at the end of 2012 to start Hack Reactor and the rest is history.
Every second counts during an immersive program and
our team has put a ton of thought into the materials that you'll be seeing here.
This course covers the first four days of Hack Reactors 12 week curriculum.
So you'll be getting a taste of the hyper fast learning that leads our students
to a 99% placement rate.
I consider these lessons the most important fundamental material you can
have under your belt, before moving towards employment in any JavaScript stack.
So whether you're new to JavaScript programming or
you've already found it confusing for years.
Together, we're going to find out just how clear and
easy it can be when you approach it the right way.